j'avais
de face
j'avais écrit un texte et j'avais fait
passer ce texte par un réviseur
professionnels pour que je puisse me
présenter et près vous présenter mes
idées un parent un français impeccable
mais à la fin je suis quand j'étais de
réfléchir sur le thème de cette
conférence ce matin il ne l'a pour
parler de langage des idées c'est à dire
idée de l'être notre l'identité mais
aussi nos idées
ce qu'on a dans la tête un g à la fin
vous me décider je me suis décidé à la
fin de ne pas suivre ce que j'avais
préparé donc je pris la décision de
jeter tous ces faits que j'avais j'avais
préparé la et de me présenter
aujourd'hui comme je suis avec toutes
mes ferrière toutes mes photos et
quelques vertus assez alors ça nous pose
un problème à vous et à moi parce que je
ne parle pas rigoureusement de france
est à l'origine explique c'est vrai que
comme interprète je parle pas mal de
langues y compris le français mais les
autres aides ils font une catégorisation
très spécial de langue on parle deux
langues à b et c est le français est
pour moi ce qu'on appelle une langue
passive une langue c'est à dire une
langue depuis laquelle je suis prêt je
suis prête à interpréter je suis très
capable de le faire mais vers laquelle
jeu nantais près de chanel parce que je
n'ai pas vraiment une maîtrise complète
cette langue donc au cours de cette
présentation
je vais vous dire de bêtise ça s'est
assuré
je ferai de foot ici c'est le cas et je
peux vous assurer que ce alors qu'un jeu
vous je vous prie de bien prendre nous
tu es à la fin m'envoyer peut-être un
courriel pour me tirer l'oreille si la
base de son avance c'est bien avec ça on
commence regardez bien cette photo là
elle a été prise à brasilia le 17 mars
1992 ses terres mardi
elle marque aussi le moment précis où je
suis devenu interprète mais
permettez-moi de revenir en arrière pour
vous raconter comment s quand je suis
arrivé quatre ans auparavant
j'entrais à l'assemblée nationale du
brésil en tant qu'employé et je
m'ennuyais ferme à noircir du papier
huit heures par jour
ce jour-là à la dernière minute
quelqu'un s'est rendu compte qu'à la fin
le prince ne parlait pas portugais et
qu'il fallait trouver quelqu'un que
pouvait faire la médiation un
linguistique
j'étais vraiment et nous y ait de jobs
du job que je faisais à l'époque et
j'avais fait courir le bruit que je
parlait couramment londres et un certain
moment et j'ai reçu un coup de fil et
deux heures après j'étais assis sur
cette scène chervin pour faire de cette
médiation
voilà le mais c'est en costume clair il
s'appelle ips pinheiro il était à
l'occasion le président de l'assemblée
nationale
en face de lui de manière oblique vous
trouvez son altesse royale le prince
philippe leduc desdits moon et le met
sur les jeunes hommes entre eux celui-là
avec plein de cheveux c'est moi voilà
donc c'est ainsi qu'a commencé dix ans
ma carrière comme interprète quelques
semaines après je me trouvais en face de
la princesse de thaïlande et
quelques mois de plus on m'a poussée
dans l'eau on dirait et j'ai nagé
pendant à ma grande surprise à la fin
j'ai aussi eu l'occasion de faire la
médiation de pas mal de l'ambassadeur
que venaient présenter leurs lettres de
créance et au sein et aussi quelques
chefs d'état y compris le dalaï lama est
aussi le meilleur milieu qui s'appelle
michel temer qui après quelques années
serait aussi ici à condition de
président le brésilien voilà donc train
c'est ça que m'est arrivé et c'est ainsi
je suis devenu l'interprète titré dès
l'assemblée nationale du président de
l'assemblée nationale qu'à l'occasion
était aussi le vice président de la
république suite à la chute de président
cola j'ai fini par quitter mon job au
congrès et j'ai ouvert un certain moment
et une agence de traduction que je
gardais par 17 ans de s'appeler dit
pressé comme le journal autriche
quelques-uns après j'étais déjà un
interprète très bien formés
je me suis décidé d'aller aux états unis
pour faire une formation académique et
j'ai pris quelques années pour faire un
master institut de monterey en
californie
et depuis une dizaine d'années j'ai été
nommé le chef interprète de lui terre
genève qui est une agence spécialisée de
l'onu
voilà donc peu à peu j'ai commencé à
avancer et c'est ça que ma que café deux
mois dix ans un interprète plus ou moins
compétents
voilà si vous
en force et vous allez voir peut-être
barack obama au fonds de 7,2 cette photo
la valeur on avance vu de l'extérieur
l'interprétation simultanée s'apparente
à de la magie de l'intérieur c'est de la
folie pure
vous passez la vie dans une cabine en
tout fait avec des collègues qu'on m'a
l'on ne connaît très bien et on est
obligé de répéter dans une langue
différente des idées et des mots
d'autres gens qu'on ne connaît pas du
tout en gardant le rythme le ton
l'intention le sens et en même temps en
cherchant des mots et des documents tout
en continuant d'interpréter il nous faut
aussi faire en sorte de dialogue
silencieux avec nos collègues du jour au
moins de gestes de regard de notre pour
qu'on puisse pourtant on peut s'en
sortir
pour empirer la situation on est
normalement jusqu'au bout de la salle de
votre côté de la salle normalement ici
dans deux cabines concept là et empêché
de faire signe à l'orateur de ralentir
de l'interrompre pour faire des
éclaircissements et tout ça face à tant
d'obstacles
on pourrait penser l'interprétation
simultanée comme quelque chose
d'impossible
pourtant elle est parfaitement faisable
c'est vraiment un beau métier c'est un
boulot extraordinaire
ça m'a donné l'occasion d'aller partout
dans le monde ça m'a posé à côté de gens
vraiment importante et ça m'a donné dans
ma propre pouvoir
l'opportunité de dire des choses très
impactante conte à la fin faire
l'histoire
j'ai eu l'occasion peut-être de lire
dans le journal le matin suivant à une
réunion exactement la phrase que j'avais
prononcé dans ma langue
c'était pas la phrase que le président
avait dit parce qu'il parlait un homme
différentes
donc il y a des trucs parfois très très
très intéressant donc on l a vraiment
pour faire l'histoire et où on en est
parti c'est bien mais c'est aussi un
boulot qui parfois est la source de
beaucoup de frustration surtout la
frustration de passer toute une vie
professionnelle en donnant expression a
des idées des autres
on utilise notre voix nos gestes tous
points pour bien faire communiquer pas
pour donner expression à ce qu'on s'en
est assez con qu'on a à dire
mais par contre pour le faire pour d
autres personnes il ya aussi ce fut ce
fort sentiment d'appartenance
parce qu'aujourd'hui je suis là juste à
côté de du président éléments aussi de
la gloire mais une fois que la lumière
s'éteint je suis juste l'interprète et
ça nous casse parfois un petit peu la
tête
il y en a deux collègues que
certainement ont eu un
de difficultés à considérer cet aspect
kt de notre profession voilà donc un
certain moment on commence à se poser la
question pourquoi pourquoi s'y consacrer
pourquoi faire ce boulot plaint des
difficultés
pourquoi passer toute sa vie de cette
manière compliquée que nous empêche de
nous exprimer
doussain est un certain moment on
commence à sentir un niveau d'un goy ce
que montrent donc c'est pas exactement
pourquoi
en même temps qu'on devient un
interprète un petit peu mieux plus
compétents et tout ça en même temps au
moins à moi ça m'arrive est constamment
ce sentiment de ne pas vraiment y est
comme si j'étais juste une voix
invisible et que j'étais quand même un
gt gt pas épanoui donc un certain moment
j'ai commencé à me poser la question
pourquoi est ce que je me sens comme ça
pourquoi l'anxiété
je fais ça depuis des années pourquoi
mais pourquoi donc j'étais à ces
points-là à l'interprète très peu sûre
de moi et ça me gênait
donc j'ai commencé à me poser la
question pourquoi un portugais
le mot pourquoi est une question mais
aussi une réponse on utilise la même le
même mot c'est pas comme en france est
attendu pour quoi et parce que un
portugais ont dit pour quelle est la
réponse est aussi pour qui ont décrit de
manière légèrement différente et un
certain moment je me suis rendu compte
que pourquoi est aussi peut-être la
meilleure réponse est pas juste la
meilleure question c'est un des sons qui
j'ai appris dans notre interprète un
interprète très célèbre mais dans le
genre une différence il s'appelle vidot
santiago ici son nom
ne vous dit rien le temps est venu
peut-être de bien connaître à vidot il
est un saxophoniste virtuose il à
parcourir le monde entier pour souffler
son saxophone il a joué avec tous les
chanteurs tous les chanteuses de la
scène internationale il a été invité par
tous les festivals djs de la planète
on est très proche parce que j'ai épousé
sa soeur il fait une trentaine d'années
donc un bel jour j'étais à la maison de
madame r ils ont commencé à se parler
je lui ai posé la question du dos tu te
présent souvent devant des milliers de
personnes
comment est ce que tu fais pour gérer
notera qu est ce que ça t'arrive
il m'a dit non ça ne m'arrive pas magie
suis un rituel très strictes il m'a
commençait donc raconter tout ce qu'il
faisait et à la fin il m'a dit que
chaque fois avant de monter sur scène
il prenait une minute pour bien
réfléchir pour faire une sorte de
méditation
mais tout ça et pour bien prier et pour
moi c'était une nouvelle une vraie
surprise qu après trente années de
tournées et tous à quelqu'un comme du
dehors suivaient cette routine avec
besoin de le faire et tout ça et je
continue à le poser la question à lui
poser la question mais pourquoi et
comment est ce qu'on fait pour m'en
sortir
il m'a dit une fois que tu connais la
raison pour laquelle tu sais quelque
chose
ainsi été va disparaître ça disparaît
complètement
il faut te poser la question et après il
m'a commencé à donner des exemples
il m'a donné quatre exemples il a dit
parmi les musiciens
il ya certains il y à certains collègues
que je joue depuis un moment une émotion
de colère ils sont fâchés
parce qu'ils sont discriminés quoi que
ce soit racialement au sexuellement au à
cause de la rage ou quoi que ce soit et
donc anti gouttes sur scène ils portent
avec eux cette colère et ils utilisent
cette émotion pour prendre leur revanche
contre le monde
et le résultat est de la bonne musique
quand même
il y en a il ya aussi quelques collègues
que le font depuis une émotion de vanité
ils ont un gradin sécurité assez ronde
killer oblige à monter sur scène et
faire de son mieux pour qu'à la fin il
ils ont les applaudissements il est
rassurant ce que vient avec ça il ya
aussi quelques autres que je joue parce
que il s'aperçoit et s'aperçoivent
qu'ils aient à la fin ils devaient faire
quelque chose d'autre
disons que ils sont là ils jouent comme
une forme des vi nations
c'est à dire peut-être que je mets mon
corps n'y est plus je devrai faire
d'autres choses mais secrètement ils
craignent n'être pas à l'auteur donc ils
continuent à jouer
il ya quelques uns comme moi par exemple
que je joue ou que faire ce qu'on fait
comme une forme de suivre les traces de
quelqu'un d'autre
quant à lui pour gagner son admiration
et son affection
c'était mon cas ailleurs au départ et
vis-à-vis mon plein
voilà un certain moment il m'a dit moi
j'ai transiter pour toutes ce genre
d'émotions il ya la fin chaque fois que
je me rendais compte que je sais que
j'étais un certain niveau jeu mais je me
forçais pour y aller de l'avant donc
j'ai transité par tout ça et aujourd'hui
je joue parce qu'un jour je me souviens
très bien
quand j'étais enfin je suis allé à un
concert dont je suis reparti
complètement changé à cause d'une note
qui j'ai entendu ça m'a changé
complètement la vie et c'est pour ça que
j'ai vu le saxophone
donc aujourd'hui je suis arrivé à un
niveau des compassions hisser sans
l'émotion que me fait jouer et donc pour
moi ce jeu essaie de faire c'est de
jouer pour transformer parce que dans
n'importe quelle foule à n'importe quel
jour il a au moins une personne prête à
être changée il je prie pour que cette
personne soit là il faut qu'elle reparte
changer voilà à ce moment là je
commençais donc à me poser cette
question
et peut-être que vous pourriez dans ce
que vous faites le vous poser aussi je
suis pas là pour vous donner des
conseils mais quelques suggestions
peut-être et des questions sont comme ça
pourquoi faites vous ce que vous faites
il faut répondre à ces questions de
manière très honnête et qu'est-ce que
vous motive vraiment à la fin si vous
trouvez qu'il émotion c'est pas la donne
qu'est ce que vous pourriez faire pour
en sortir est peut-être passé à une
émotion différente qui peut être vous
donnez kiss à l'envi ou l'énergie de
faire les choses que vous faites à
partir d'une émotion différente que vous
dépasse qui n'est pas totalement cintrée
même il ya la fin pour qui jouer vous
parce que comme interprète
on se souvient très souvent je fait que
chaque fois qu'on et autocentrée si
parfois je perds une phrase je mets ta
stig à cause de ça je perds aussi la
suivante si je me mets dans les
applaudissements parce que moi j'ai bien
compris ça a bien fait j'espère aussi ce
que vient train
donc on a appris qu'on interprète je
suis je suis je peux je peux vous dire
c'est qui et pour bien faire ce métier
il faut se dépasser et donc centré votre
attention sur quelqu'un d'autre
peut-être qu'il vous faut trouver
quelqu'un d'autre à qui se concentrent
un pour mes affaires pour mieux faire
votre bible votre boulot alors ce sont
deux questions difficiles et peut-être
que les réponses vous échapperont
pendant un certain temps mal est posée
et agir en fonction des les intuitions
qu'en découle
c'est le seul moyen de continuer de
l'avant
en attendant peut-être vous pourriez
essayer certains aspects kt de cette
routine de ville de santiago
c'est à dire prendre une petite minute
pour vous raccorder exactement la vraie
raison de votre présence dans votre
métier ou ailleurs
au delà de la cabine d'interprétation ou
de la scène ils attentent de découvertes
à faire de rêve matérialiser deux mythes
sur le point de tomber tout ce qu'il
faut c'est de jouer une note précisément
avec émotion de prononcer un mot avec
compassion et de manière précise et
chaque jour dans n'importe quelle foule
il y à au moins une personne prête à
être changé j'espère que cette personne
soit aller coûte aujourd'hui que
j'espère que vous êtes
cette personne je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]